Suppose we physicists didn't tell anyone
how and why the laws of physics work.
We just performed them and we said
it's because we have powers.
If we did that, we would be running the world. People would be genuflecting as they
walk by us. People would be bringing us
chickens from their farms. People would be
begging that we don't incinerate them
with our antimatter device. The fact is
the people who are doing the research
into magnetism, electromagnetism, more
broadly... they tended to be educators,
academicians, not charlatans. And so only
if your charlatan will you not tell
someone how something works, pretend you
have the power and then you have the
power over that person. That is
diabolical so it is incumbent upon the
educated educators class, if you can call
it that, to say exactly what it is we're
doing and why and then it's not
mysterious. You could do it too. You could
be a physicist. You could probe the
operations of nature as we do. I have
powers and you don't, but I explain
them and therefore you don't come
running to me thinking I'm your your
demigod for having these powers. You say
what book did you learn this out of I
want to be able to do that too. So yeah
that we could have been magicians or
charlatans. That's an education
issue right there and rather than beat
adults over the head because it's not
their fault they weren't educated or
wasn't exposed or whatever, I think we
just have to rethink K through 12 and what is
taught - what science is how, and why it
works. For me, science is vaccine against
charlatans. It enables you to know
when someone is full of shit and when
they're not. And that's power.
It's power of protection for yourself so
you will not be exploited by those who
do not have your best interests in mind.
Hey! If you like this please remember
everything that we do can be found
commercial-free, plus exclusive original
content all on StarTalkAllAccess.com